ladies and gentlemen we have the one and
only the mastermind himself
meat canyon here on the ship today
mythical meat canyon mythical weekend if
you don't know
who meat canyon is he's the king of
[ __ ] up cartoons oh what do you think
the what do you think your most [ __ ]
up cartoon is what do you think is the
most darkest cartoon you made i mean the
willy wonka one
was pretty like i was surprised that
actually stayed up because it's like so
i mean it's like a direct reference to
like jeffrey epstein and like all that
stuff and like it's you're like a child
like following him you know right and
it's like
i was pretty surprised by that but i
mean i don't know like it's
but by the end of it especially with
like animation you've seen something
like 80 million times so you kind of
just like it just has no effect on you
anymore right so you kind of just hope
you cross your fingers that like
it like still lands and it's fun but it
also doesn't go too far to where it just
gets completely removed and you get like
a guideline strike or something you ever
had a moment where you finished one and
like that
you know you feel desensitized and then
maybe you're like about to send it live
and do you ever get it was there one
that was maybe like
like you wanted to hit cancel maybe just
like not upload that i mean probably the
willy wonka one like it's very like it's
like so not subtle what it's trying to
do you know and like after you why like
watched a bunch of times and it was a
big headache because it was like the
first time that we did like a
po like a mixture of 2d and 3d so it's
like a 3d uh tracking camera so it's
like you're kind of just like following
him as if he's actually walking through
the space and stuff yeah um but like the
lines in it so you're like just stressed
about that the whole time and then you
kind of sit down and watch the final
thing again and it's like getting ready
to upload and like willy wonka's like on
his hands and he's like looking back and
he's like nothing wrong with window
shopping oh [ __ ] and you're just like
you're like i don't
was that too far like i don't like i
don't i don't know let's find out yeah
exactly
[Laughter]
let's see susan what do you think susan
how do you feel so you said we do you
have a team that helps yeah yeah
definitely like as the channel's grown
i've been lucky enough to like have
enough money to actually fund things so
like the productions can get better and
we can still uh maintain the kind of
upload schedule we do i mean as as
creatives it's like really hard to
offload the creativity and delegate that
so and i mean i i can only imagine
that's
so much more in animation because it's
like it's it's everything right it's
your style it's your idea so how do you
like how do you delegate to people and
like what does that look like
yeah i mean delegation
and like even just time management and
stuff has been a huge learning process
but
i think that it's just like one not
being such a huge like i'm not a huge
stickler on making everything
absolutely perfect like i think like
some of the imperfections are like what
makes it kind of it's still a charming
internet video because it's not
something that's like on netflix or
something where people are gonna be like
with that budget really you know yeah so
um it's just about finding a good group
of people that can like maintain the
work schedule and like know how to like
work fast with what we have and also
just like being able to know how to do
things economically and like make things
make sense also it means like also you
have a fun idea how can you consolidate
it down to get it done in like 12 days
right so that's like the the biggest uh
hurdle that we've had to do but
yeah great but do you still draw
everything and voice everything i voice
i voice just about everything just
because it it's ten times easier yeah
like it's very hard like it's hey just
plug in a [ __ ] mic and record
something but people were like uh i'll
give it to you but it just takes forever
so being able to do it yourself
immediately and then like
set up like your radio play and then
your animatic and all that stuff
so much easier just do it to yourself
i do do all the design still just
because it's like the style but like in
terms of like the animation and stuff uh
it's all split up between the whole team
stuff how big is a team
we go from about three to four animators
per video nice do you ever get
frustrated by that dilemma where you
factor time against your creativity i i
like i find myself doing that a lot
where i'm like
i would do this but there's not enough
time so that's like do you ever get
essential youtube yeah yeah i think i
think everybody feels that for sure i
think it's like trying to think of ways
where
i've tried to make the best of it like
because i think if you get in that like
loop i feel like you're constantly in
this loop of being like i kind of hate
what i'm making all the time because
it's like a lesser version of what i'm
thinking yeah so it's like how can i
make like
with these constraints of starting off
with being like i want to write this
script in like two pages no okay and
then try and like breed creativity out
of restrictions nice which has been
that's a great actually which has been
like really fulfilling in a lot of ways
like how can you and then like you find
out like this economical way is like 10
times better and so much easier than
doing it this super convoluted like you
know crazy way that you imagine in your
head yeah so just trying to make um time
for that and then also like with bigger
projects like
letting that breathe and like enjoying
the process more with that and then
considering like the turnaround time
with youtube as something that's just
like we need we need to get it done yeah
so yeah
i remember like there was a time on
youtube where animation was huge
and then eventually they made changes to
the algorithm
that killed it off almost completely the
genre like went away because no one
could make any money yeah and i kind of
thought that it had stayed that way
until i found your channel and realized
you were getting 10 million views per
video and people were like
you know like
your channel was huge
and so that has that like returned like
does youtube reward is there money to be
made on youtube now in animation i think
that there is like i think that it's
totally viable i think that it's just
you have to get like it's a business
yeah at the end of the day like i think
a lot of those animators that had to
leave back then was they're making like
if you look at this i mean they still
hold up today like they're so good
so and it is and it sucks to say it's
kind of like what you're saying of like
my whole philosophy behind it was i like
also really dumb quick things and then
move on to the next thing and like treat
that
uh almost as from like a business
standpoint but then also feel like you
can compete with vloggers
and compete because that's what you're
doing is you need to like live in the
ecosystem that youtube is and you can't
[ __ ] about everything you have to like
how do you adapt to it and that's like
one way to adapt and because of that
it's like you know am i making
like top tier like this is my magnum
opus it's like no probably not yet but
it's at least allowing me to like fund
those things and figure out what exactly
that kind of project look like looks
like
for the future but i definitely think so
i also think that there's like so many
great animation channels out right now
yeah it's really really what are some
uh worthy kids okay it's fantastic
brilliant artist there's a sploshy
there's another one these are like more
like i guess weird i'll just list off
some but like ethereal snake flash gets
um
[ __ ] uh
sick animation is still doing stuff and
he's great he's been around forever um
yeah i don't know just just tons like
yeah if if also cass van de pool you
probably see him his stuff blows up all
the time he gets some awesome views too
so i've also noticed there's some
channels that kind of rip your style a
little bit do you notice that i don't i
mean okay if even if they do it's like
it's just it's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] up
thing i mean i i don't know like i think
if it's like as long as you just don't i
guess copy the video idea then i'm like
whatever but in terms of like style and
stuff i don't think that mine is like
too
crazy you know
honed in i think it's just like a [ __ ]
up version of stuff yeah that's fair
what do you like okay because when i
look at your uh
whenever whenever i watch your videos i
get
a weird like warm feeling of like
newgrounds.com
um yeah yeah like
were there
what do you think like as a kid
maybe like
molded like this like sense of humor
that you have like is there anything
specific like i mean you could say that
the new grounds people definitely did
like i love
psychic pebbles and oni and all those
guys like they do amazing work still i
didn't i unfortunately didn't get into
them super super late i didn't have
internet until i was in college no way
so like didn't have internet yeah dude
really about that yeah what
yeah just lived in yeah
i didn't
my dad had playboys and it was just
awful like he's like don't look for him
it's just in a stack
so clear you're like you really didn't
put it i think he was like find it but
uh
yeah don't look for them under the bed
you don't want to look it's also weird
it's like a monthly subscription yeah
what are you doing with that yeah
i always liked how those came in like
the like the censored bags like that
changes anything it's like oh yeah no
that's the bag with tits in it yeah for
sure
but otherwise not i mean like early
adult swim was really awesome um and
then from there just like tons of like
really gruesome detailed like uh comic
books like spawn yeah and [ __ ] oh it's
just like skin and teeth and like folds
and stuff so yeah
what
did you live in an area they just didn't
have internet or yeah we lived in like a
i lived on a like a cattle farm that
like just did even like the satellite
internet didn't even yeah just out there
yeah yeah so like
no kansas city missouri oh yeah right
but the uh
but like i had friends ahead internet
but it's like we would go and on like
ebon's world back yeah i did i didn't i
just didn't know everything that was out
there you know so
it wasn't until like 2007 when like i
started knowing about like youtube and
[ __ ] and wow
damn so is that about when you
discovered new grounds as well
no i really didn't know about new ground
so i was like 19 when i was in school
for animation
how have you not seen this this is like
a thing and i was like i don't know damn
but it was super inspiring because all
those guys it was showed that you can
like do it by yourself yeah because i
think before that everybody's like i
want to work for don't swim
or something yeah right
but after you see that you're just
like [ __ ] i just want to make stupid
[ __ ] with my friends yeah there's some
really horrible sorry okay there's some
horrible [ __ ] on newgrounds i remember
like there's like this flash animation
game for like being a school shooter
oh i remember that
yeah it was like really but they made it
really like juvenile looking and all
like you know all the characters and the
students were like round bubbly
characters and luke can you search most
[ __ ] up new grounds games and like
killing people is like
really satisfying like the animation
you're like
damn what am i doing like even at that
age i had enough to be like this is
[ __ ] up yeah man killing people and
tons of [ __ ] games and stuff yeah that's
what people
people people love yeah yeah that's what
sells
murder and [ __ ] games
it's true yeah i don't know why they're
i don't know why they keep trying to
push fortnite scorsese has been pushing
that for 40 years yeah yeah yeah
epic games give us a [ __ ] game already
did you find it luke or no
enough
uh albinoblacksheep.com remember that
one yeah wow jesus bro oh yeah what was
that it was like i had that one where it
was like the saddam hussein thing oh my
god i took that clip from bruce almighty
where steve carl's doing that yeah but
it looped that yeah forever and he's
like flying around yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of bad [ __ ] on there too
weird a weirdly like wholesome animation
that i used to love
uh was zhao zhao you remember that like
it was just like a stick figure it was
like they recreated like it man as like
a stick figure and they'd be these
really intense animations of like a
stick figure fighting like 30 other
stick figures and i remember just being
like thoroughly
impressed with like
you know how they would they took like
this 2d character and then like they
give him weapons and like it would
present like 3d space and
the coordination with all that just was
really dope what is like the ideal
career i guess for a modern-day animator
uh
[ __ ] god
you gotta really love it yeah yeah cause
your ass is getting abused 100
especially work for a studio system yeah
it's just like such an underappreciated
art form yeah and stuff i i don't know
if like did the does anyone know like
the strike going on did the strike
happen here um yeah the guild i don't
know if it was animation i think it was
like more writer and stuff but it could
have but i don't know if it got enough
like media play um yeah i don't know
either but and is that changing with
nfts because i think like we're kind of
going through this like renaissance
for in terms of like artists rights and
yeah well i think that the biggest
problem with nfts is just the eco
problem so i think it's hard for people
to justify making money off of how bad
it is on the ecosystem yeah um and i
think like if it gets to a place where
it can be more green along with all
crypto i think that you will see more
people have an opportunity to
actually make something [ __ ] awesome
and it feels in this digital format
can't be as regarded as like a francis
bacon painting do you say things do you
see there's this article i saw yesterday
uh all like of the chinese mining
outfits uh quadrupled their power draw
in the last like couple months really
yeah
and is it clean energy or no no it's
like horrible yeah
yeah i feel like we'd hear about it more
if it was just like oh my god this is so
much clean energy i think it's gonna be
solved in a year i think one year yes i
don't think it'll be that quick bruh
that's very optimistic well because
because of like proof of stake and
everything like
that's why so that's child like
that's that's that's like your taste
that's like
men with scotch drinking they're like i
think ethereum 2.0 could be green and
then the kid like walks up and he's like
it's going to be better by next year
[Laughter]
i'm just glad we're the grown man in
this scene yeah there you go yeah
no i think with like proof of stake and
other cryptos like solana or whatever i
know it hasn't happened yet but i think
it has to happen there's no other way
that we can i mean we can go we i mean
just to take it there i mean like we've
needed to make cars green since ever and
like that [ __ ] hasn't happened so like i
have zero what is happening hey but the
ford lightning yeah right yeah america's
number one yeah
i mean it is happening but
it's gonna i mean i think so either the
world dies and we all [ __ ] burn and
perish that will happen because i think
that's good that will happen before 100
okay i think the cars aren't going away
the blockchain is not going away yeah i
think that will happen and then as it's
happening
then
every like government person would be
like well we have the electric cars now
and crypto works it's like it's too late
bruh yeah there's no ozone i just think
the energy argument is just like in
in in the
like dot-com boom
like people would have been like oh
don't plug in your computers everyone's
getting a personal computer it's [ __ ]
up the
yeah energy everyone's using so much
more energy can we just stop making
websites
i mean yeah people be like no what but i
think maybe it's the fact that like
crypto like it's just it's just like
persistent it's just like machines like
crunching i don't know i mean i guess
that doesn't really change the power
draw but i want to be on record by
saying that i don't know
hardly anything neither so these content
sections when people are none of us do
i'm just going to be completely honest
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about it's all right do you know how the
internet works you can go i completely
don't know what i'm talking about and
this is my rough opinion on it
guaranteed there's always one person
who's like yeah you're still a [ __ ]
idiot for even guessing how dare you
yeah yeah cody wants the world to burn
yeah no
what i think's gonna happen is you're
gonna be at this crossroads where the
earth is like dead like people are
it's horrible yeah i'm not going to say
yeah but
sick nfts that's true yeah you're like
dude check my wallet the uh but the uh i
think there's gonna be a giant farewell
concert
[ __ ] yeah dude yeah
and then everybody's gonna be is living
up in the north pole because it's the
warmest spot or it's like the most
livable spot now because the rest is
just [ __ ]
[ __ ] right
yeah yeah it's like doji cat up there
this is like this is like 20 years okay
20 years from now you think it's gonna
happen yeah this [ __ ] is going down bro
yeah